foreign
that Fidelity Investments with its
quarterly retirement analysis has
discovered the same thing that we
already knew from the Ramsey study of
millionaires done a few years back the
largest study of millionaire has ever
done the title is of the article is move
over crypto a record number of workers
are becoming millionaires with their
boring 401ks and IRAs I love to hear
this news the more boring the more
excited I get as an actual investment
strategy so here's what it says meet the
newly minted millionaires next door they
didn't put all their money into
Microsoft type stock that made them Rich
they didn't take a chance on speculating
in crypto with its crazy volatility or
start a business that they sold to some
billionaire no these are government
workers civil servants Educators
military folks managers co-workers
clocking in just like you and uh many
never earn six-figure salaries which we
found in our millionaire study one-third
never had a six-figure household income
in a single working year and so in its
quarterly retirement analysis Fidelity
reported that the number of IRAs and
401K millionaires hit an all-time high
that's impressive there it is and not
shocking 401K millionaires by
translation they had over a million
dollars in their 401K they may or may
not be actual millionaires depending on
how much debt they have but uh because
you're you're an actual millionaire is
what you own minus what you owe is your
net worth your assets monitor
liabilities but assuming that they don't
have a bunch of other debt running
around they've got over a million in
their 401K they very likely are
millionaires and that's what we found we
found that the typical millionaire uh it
took them 12 to 15 years to get there
uh 89 did not inherit the money that
made them a millionaire
did not 9 out of ten did not that's
actual facts not your broke
brother-in-law who votes left Wing's
opinion
this is actual facts by actual airtight
research okay so 89 did not inherit the
money that made them a millionaire and
we can actually prove that with the
largest study of millionaires ever done
now having said that then we say take
twice the average is 12 to 15 years to
get there we had two primary components
to their net worth that caused them to
get their first one to five million
dollars of net worth one of those was a
paid for home which we found that the
average millionaire pays off their home
in 11 years and the other is their
retirement account and so when you add
those things together when you get a
paid for home and you've invested 15 of
your household income into 401ks and
IRAs it's amazing how quickly you get
there in the span of your lifetime it's
a blip and 79 percent of millionaires in
our research reach millionaire status
through their employer-sponsored
retirement plans so this is not a theory
it's uh pretty simple guys pretty simple
uh and it is kind of like the uh like
the article says it's a bit boring
there's really nothing nothing you get
to brag about there's no Adrenaline Rush
yeah you're bright you know you're
playing golf or you're fishing with your
buddies you don't get to brag and say
you did something really brilliant all
you did was just steadily invest and pay
off your house
pending then I can't watch crypto over
the weekend 24 7 go up and down up and
down which Bitcoin just had another cry
a crash no I know I'm sorry to hear your
feelings Dave oh I hate it when I'm
right do you not really that was sarcasm
I sensed a little bit of that I actually
don't want anybody to lose money I'm not
wishing for someone to get hurt that's
not that is the truth but it's the
crypto Bros who think Dave's out of
touch and they have been wearing me out
too so giving me a hard time like I'm an
idiot all over social media because you
know once you join the crypto bandwagon
you're like oh yeah you know it's just
it's like you've we talked about this at
The Building Wealth event Dave the
people who are into crypto are really
into crypto they're obsessed they're
trying to sell all their buddies on
crypto and so we came to the conclusion
that cryptocurrency is just Mary Kay for
young men but you don't get the pink
Cadillac that's upsetting no pink
Cadillac maybe in the metaverse they
have a digital version a virtual you can
get an nft of a Cadillac yeah and get a
picture of it you don't really have a
Cadillac well it's a virtual I wonder
what you don't really have one I'm just
saying virtual means not really the next
thing Dave this is if I virtually send
my wife flowers on the anniversary I
don't get anything I'm just saying she's
not gonna like this it's not gonna be a
happy day at Ramsay okay I've virtually
sent you flowers darling that means I
almost did it yeah I think the next
trend is going to be nft timeshares it's
a sense of ownership of a sense of
ownership
in the metaverse you buy the timeshare
so we can both live next to Snoop Dogg
for one weekend at a time
this is not a far future Dave I think
I'm a I'm a fortune teller oh this is a
redundancy redundancy Department
we're losing our minds oh we're gonna
get
an nft timeshare a sense of ownership of
a sense of ownership that's how that
works uh that is what the timeshare
people tell you you have a sense of
ownership which means you don't really
have ownership but you kind of can get a
whiff of it yes a whiff I like that
whiff
oh man
this is the culture oh this is what
we're up against Dave Lord Jesus help us
oh we're going to do a nft timeshare
next door to Snoop Dogg I lose brain
cells every time I read headlines like
that well if you were next door to Snoop
Dogg you might be that's true
I'm gonna google that can I get virtual
second hand
that is a Google search waiting to
happen
oh what a time to be alive did you ever
think in your lifetime this would be a
reality because you've seen a lot of
stupid stuff in your day over 30 years
but it's getting out of control even for
you hey man I I mean no no I didn't have
any idea this is um
I I I actually didn't think the internet
was gonna work so you're one of those
you went oh this is a fad it's like you
want to spend five thousand dollars and
build a website what this is when it was
first starting you know with dial up all
right 14-4 hook up right
I remember those days I wore out those
AOL free trials hey Dave you got that
internet
yeah yeah I got that internet and you
had to either use the phone or use the
internet see I'm not that exactly that
young facts yeah yeah you could fax
stuff I walked up or there was emails
yeah man when I got in the real estate
business in 1978 we had these things
called facts machines we were members of
e r a electronic Realty Associates yeah
we would send over this Magic Machine
black and white pictures of a listing in
another city
and it would print off took it about
four minutes to print one page and uh it
was an electronic people were buying
real estate based off of that no they
would they would agree to come look at
that piece of real estate with you they
did they were not dumb enough to buy it
off of that that's what's happened dumb
enough to buy it off of that happened
later
and they're coming from other cities
where there's no desperate to buy a
house I haven't even seen it I'll buy it
sight unseen no inspection no appraisal
don't care 100 000 over asking yeah yeah
I'm gonna I'm just in a bidding war oh
we've lost our minds
uh yeah should they teach critical
thinking still in school is that there's
no class on that right no we don't teach
thinking anywhere in the in the United
States it's we don't think anymore
uh so we used to have like arguments and
debates because we didn't have Google to
solve it oh yeah that's a good fight now
because somebody Google's the answer
it's me he's talking about me you and
Rachel are fighting and I got guys it
was 2018. you go we were having fun
arguing why'd you have to go and ruin it
because Rachel and I do have fun arguing
so if you want to be a newly minted
millionaire according to this article it
is backing up the details that are in
the book baby steps Millionaires and in
the study that is outlined in the back
of the book baby steps millionaires now
if you want to be a billionaire it's a
different formula
you will not become a billionaire with
your 401k
it's mathematically impossible
but a billion is one thousand million
that's a lot of millions so just in case
you were wondering your one thousandth
of a billionaire
when you're a millionaire wow you're
just a peon you're not even close at
that point yeah you're just a pee on it
but you can have a great life as a
millionaire you don't need to be a
billionaire that's a greater life than
if you don't
there it is perspective that's what we
needed there we go thank you for using
your critical thinking skills you still
have a few brain cells left Dave turns
out I'm I'm worried about
this uh sense of ownership of a sense of
ownership next to Snoop Dogg with
secondhand virtual smoke I'm just
worried about this hole this whole line
of thinking George has got me upset well
the only way to make money there is if
you're the one selling it so get to
selling some nfts Dave
um I'm gonna have to hard pass hard pass